the song clocks when did you write that
uh
um 2002. and is that another 10-minute
like thought process or is that working
like 15.
15 minutes why do the hits come so
quickly what is that
i get i don't know why where were you
when clocks came into your head that you
got
liverpool in liverpool what were you
doing at the time uh writing
you're sitting around in liverpool
writing like in other words it's one of
your times to sit and write
how does this come to you okay this i'll
switch over here all right
i love to know about this no one really
asked me about this i'm asking you about
it
i got you here i'm going to ask you all
right where are you at a place called
par street in liverpool so we went to
liverpool obviously for all the
same reasons everyone does to kind of
get some beatles
vibes as it were are the beatles your
heroes uh one of them right
i have a lot though are they the best
group that ever existed either one of
them
one of them who is better influences
well you've got to put stevie wonder and
the stones and
right i mean there's so many that's
right oh it's bob marley
i love bob no woman no cry yeah let's go
play a little i'll sing
[Music]
okay
[Music]
there's no number one with you i'll
probably bob marley is number one get
back to clock
okay all right so you're sitting around
you're in liverpool you want inspiration
you went
okay this is actually uh so i had this
and and i showed that simple thing to
johnny who plays guitar and he
he was there very early and he was
playing guitar and he
he came up with the chords underneath
that is a powerful
little riff there right when you have
something like that but then he put the
chords under it and then the whole song
came out
like real quick do a little please okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
wow